Khloe Kardashian shuts down claims about
her weight loss after an Internet troll
accuses her of misusing medicine isn't
that crazy the accusation came after the
Kardashian star shared her latest
magazine photo shoot on Instagram
displaying her fitbot we all want to be
cute over here okay yeah and the user
accused Chloe of achieving her slim
figure by using semi-glutide an
anti-diabetic injectable used for
chronic weight management it sold under
a few names most notably ozampic which
is rumored to be abused by Hollywood
stars to shed lbs fast but Coco slammed
the claim saying let's not discredit my
years of working out I get up five days
a week at 6 a.m to train working out is
one of my new obsessions healthy
obsessions the good American founder
also added please stop with your
assumptions I guess New Year still means
mean people that's bizarre to me and you
would think people would be happy that
I'm staying healthy
Health then there's Chloe's new bangs
yep she rocked this Fierce hair during
the shoot and said they changed the
shape of her face so a user commented oh
it was the bangs that changed your face
so much in these pics Coco's quick clap
back I openly talk about my nose job and
anyone who looks up to me must know I've
lost over 60 pounds over the years so
recently the only change is the bangs I
didn't know I had to do a running list
it's also not what you say it's how you
say it
so Coco's latest looks may not be
everyone's favorite but she does have a
fan in Britney Spears
[Music]
back in November the Pop Princess
praised the reality star style from
Beyonce's birthday party tweeting she's
the reason I crimp my hair now how often
hot is that but I don't see how hers is
more puffy I'm working on it she's
beautiful I love it Coco responded but
gave all the credit to her Glam Squad
saying quote you are so sweet I wish I
could say I did this myself but I did
not huh you're beautiful it's a
beautiful thing
foreign